وانتقدت كوريا الشماليه الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيرش على خلفيه
تصريحاته بشان تجربتي بيون جانج صاروخيه
الاخيره وقالت ان سلوك المجهفه والمتحيزه
للامين العام للامم المتحده على حد وصف
البيان هو المسؤول الى حد ما عن خطوره
الوضع في شبه الجزيره الكوريه وقال البيان
الذي نشرته وكاله الانباء الرسميه ان
عمليات اطلاق صواريخ الصواريخ الاخيره هي
مجرد ورد فعل للدفاع عن النفس في مواجهه
الاستفزازات العسكريه الامريكيه وفق ما
جاء في البيان وكان الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو جوترش
بعمليات الاطلاق الاخيره لكوريا
وحاسه بيونجا على توقفه فورا عن اي عمل
استفزازيا اخر على حد وصفه
قالت كوريا الشماليه انها لم تعقد اي صفقه
اسلحه مع روسيا وليست لديها خطط لذلك
مستقبلا وقال بيان نقلته وكاله الانباء
الرسميه انه اذا لم يسبق لبيونجيانغ ابرام
وصفقات اسلحه مع روسيا ولا تخطط للقيام
بذلك في المستقبل وتهمه البيان والولايات
المتحده بالاصرار على نشر شائعه تعاملات
اسلحه كوريا الشماليه وروسيا وياتي موقف
الموقف الكوري والشمالي في خطاب متوترات
متصاعده حول شبه الجزيره الكوريه بعد ما
اجرت بيونجا سلسله تجارب صاروخيه شملت
احداها اطلاق صواريخ او صاروخ مال السيره
الذان على مناورات هي الاكبر على الاطلاق
للقوات الجويه الامريكيه
والكوريه الجنوبيه اطلقت عليها اسم عاصفه
اليقظه